Hi everyone.
I'm in Manhattan today talking to my publishers,
Penguin Random House about my next book,
but I thought I'd take this opportunity to make an announcement that you might
find of interest as some of you may know and the rest of you are learning.
Now I'm debating Marxist philosopher,
Slavoj Jijak in Toronto,
April 19th at the Sony Center.
Doctors Jijak is a Slovenian philosopher and professor at the Institute for
Sociology and Philosophy at the University of Louisiana who's works on cultural
studies,
psychoanalysis and above all for the purposes of our debate,
Marxism are world renowned,
the topic happiness,
Marxism versus capitalism.
The live tickets have already sold out.
We've decided in consequence to experiment with live streaming.
The discussion,
I'm still going to post the video recording on Youtube and the audio on podcast
in mid May in the same manner as usual.
However,
my team has discussed the possibility that people might be interested in
participating online live.
Maybe there's something attractive and worthwhile about being there when it
happens,
even electronically the same way.
There's something positive about viewing in Olympic sports event when it
happens,
even though you could more conveniently watch it at a different time,
maybe it has something to do with the sense of a shared public collective
experience.
In any case,
we're offering everyone this opportunity as an experiment and an investigation.
Who knows?
Maybe some of you want to organize this Dziedzic party.
You can subscribe to the live stream at Peterson versus Jijak Com.
That's Peterson versus dziedzic.com it comes at a cost 1495 this enables us to
produce it professionally and to ensure we hope that the broadcast is of high
quality and reliability as well as to produce whatever profit might ensue.
Dr [inaudible],
by the way,
has announced his intention to donate his share to charity.
We hope you find this livestream opportunity and the debate itself of interest.
I might also remind you that I'm speaking in New York on 12 rules for life on
April 17th at the beacon theater and then on May 8th in London at the Apollo.
Information about all of this can be found@wwwdotjordanwouldbepeterson.com
forward slash events.
Thanks for your attention to this announcement and for all your continued
support.
Bye Bye.